[Applause]
[Music]
In the untamed wild, a creature will not
strike unless as it senses danger or is
driven by hunger acting solely out of
the primal instinct to survive.
[Music]
Yet man is a different beast. Man
inflicts suffering upon his fellow
beings and other creatures not from
necessity but from an insatiable greed
and a thirst for power.
The annals of history are drenched in
the blood of innocent victims of
genocides and mass slaughters,
sacrificed at the altar of domination
and rapaciousness.
This film is a solemn denouncement of
the ideologies of aggression, a poignant
reflection on the senseless brutality
that has scarred humanity.
[Music]
The BBC's reported on camps like these
in western China where about a million
weaggguers and other Muslim minorities
have been detained without trial.
1.1 crore Weaggguers reside in Shenzhan,
China.
Since 2017, the Chinese government has
imprisoned over 10 lakh weaguers,
imposing intense surveillance, religious
restrictions, forced labor, and
sterilization.
>> Chinese technology giant Huawei has
reportedly tested an artificial
intelligence software which could
identify the faces of Uigur minorities
and send an alert to the Chinese
authorities.
While the Muslim world frequently
condemns Islamophobia in the West,
there remains a striking silence on
China's suppression of Islam and weaguer
culture. Equally unsettling is the
global indifference to the plight of
weaguer Muslims,
a quiet disregard that leaves a profound
question unressed.
But oppression of Muslim communities
isn't confined to China alone.
Across the globe, another grim reality
unfolds. A story of violence often born
from within.
A landmark report by the French think
tank Fondo
supported by the global terrorism
database reveals that between 1979 and
Islamist extremism was responsible for
33,769
terrorist attacks worldwide
claiming over 1 lak 67,000 lives
alarming ly 91.2%
of the victims were Muslims.
Highlighting the brutal reality of
Islamist violence,
it overwhelmingly pres
it claims to defend.
[Music]
Crows of people in India were killed in
the medieval period by Islamic invaders.
Will Durant called the Islamic conquest
of India probably the bloodiest story in
history. Professor KS L estimated 6 to8
cr deaths due to Islamic invasions in
India from 100 AD to 1525 AD.
US President Donald Trump has promised
to build a Hindu Holocaust memorial in
Washington DC while addressing an event
on Diwali.
>> I fully endorse the idea of building a
Hindu Holocaust memorial in DC.
>> Modeled on the United States Holocaust
Memorial Museum in Washington DC, which
documents Nazi atrocities against the
Jewish community. This proposed memorial
recognizes the immense suffering Hindu
society endured during centuries of
invasion and oppression by Islamic
forces.
The 20th century witnessed death and
slaughter on an unprecedented scale. It
was the century of the Holocaust and two
world wars of communist, Nazi, fascist
and military dictators who between them
killed more than 10 core people.
[Music]
The Jewish Holocaust was one of
history's darkest periods with millions
of Jews enduring unimaginable suffering
and loss.
Research shows that this extreme trauma
altered their genes, impacting both
survivors and their descendants.
In the first generation, in a Holocaust
survivor, it suggests that there has
been an adaptation or a response to a
horrendous environmental event. And in
the second generation, it suggests that
there has also been a response of the
offspring to this parental trauma.
It's crucial to study the Hindu
community similarly as they too faced
centuries of persecution and genocide to
understand its lasting effects on their
descendants.
Partition of India in 1947 unleashed
Muslim League's megalomaniac killing
machine. Millions were massacred,
provoking a response from the other side
too.
Around 80 lakh non-Muslims moved from
Pakistan to India and around 75 lakh
Muslims moved from India to West and
East Pakistan. According to the
government of India figures, the
estimates of those killed have varied
from 5 lakh to over 10 lakh. The
generally accepted figure stands at
around five lakh according to the
government of India data.
Bureau of police research and
development BPR&D reveals 43 active
terror groups from Pakistan in India.
India ranks third globally in terror
incidents following Iraq and
Afghanistan.
South Asia terrorism portal reveals that
47,130
persons were killed in terror related
events between the years 2000 and 2024.
Between 1947 and 2023,
35,098
people were killed in communal riots all
over the country.
Government of India data shows that over
2,900 cases of communal rioting were
registered in the country between 2017
and 2021.
The economic repercussions of terrorism
and communal violence in India are
staggering. For instance, the Esso Cham
report highlights the impact of just 60
hours of terror during the 2611 attacks
leading to a loss of 4,000 cr rupees to
Mumbai alone.
This event inflicted an overall loss of
hundred billion US to the Indian economy
with foreign direct investment taking a
significant hit of 20 billion US
according to the Asia Economics
Institute.
In 2017, the Sydneybased Institute for
Economics and Peace calculated the total
monetary impact of violence in India,
which was equivalent to 9% of the
country's GDP
amounting to a colossal $1 trillion US
in purchasing power pars.
This translates to approximately 80 lakh
cr Indian rupees for that year.
Moving into 2020, violence continued to
drain the economy, incurring a cost of
$646 billion US or about 53,700
cr Indian rupees, representing 6% of the
nation's GDP.
The Delhi riots of that year highlighted
a troubling trend. A new model of urban
warfare allegedly orchestrated by the
Naxal Jihadi Alliance involving groups
such as CPI, Mauist, PFI, Jamaati,
Islami and other jihadist organizations.
This ongoing threat of violence and
terrorism imposes a heavy economic toll
on India posing significant challenges
to its stability and growth.
[Music]
In the words of Turkeykey's president
Rashab Taip Erdwan,
mosques are our barracks,
the domes are helmets, the minurates are
bayonets,
and the Muslim faithful
are soldiers.
This declaration underscores the
significance of mosques in the lives of
Muslims.
>> Highlighting their role in the pursuit
of global Islamic supremacy
for Muslims worldwide. The mosque is
more than a place of worship.
It serves as a central institution where
various activities including religious
education and community gatherings take
place.
It is important to note that many
mosques are affiliated with madras where
young students receive religious
instruction including teachings that
promote a vision of widespread Islamic
significance.
Islam has a strong congregational
tradition with a customary ritual that
encourages all Muslims to attend Friday
prayers in mosques.
>> In India, often the crowd of the
believers overflow out of the mosques to
the streets. During these prayers, imams
deliver religious sermons as part of the
postnamutba.
We are heading to Sundar Nagari in
northeast Delhi near the Uttar Pradesh
border. We have received multiple
reports from local residents and TV
journalists of rising aggression against
the minority Hindu community
rally over Dalit's murder in Delhi.
That's the breaking news.
Hindu
Sundari, predominantly home to Dalits
and economically disadvantaged Hindus,
is transforming into a nogo zone in the
heart of the national capital.
Fear and uncertainty have gripped the
Dalith community as a result of a
growing Hindu exodus from the area.
Push.
This place has become a hub for
profitable illegal enterprises,
including stolen car rackets and
unauthorized car dismantling. Ling
workshops
without license.
Unregulated animal slaughter in
residential areas is a long-standing
tool used by religious zealots to
desecrate Hindu places of worship.
I'm saying
Once a Hindu majority locality, Sundar
Naguri has witnessed a dramatic
demographic shift with the Hindu
community now reduced to just 40% of the
population.
This shift is fueled by a surge in
criminality, harassment of Hindu women,
bullying and a general breakdown in law
and order. prompting many Hindu families
to leave. Local testimonies paint a
picture of a crumbling environment where
holanism and intimidation are daily
realities.
[Music]
Tuck, tuck, tuck, tuck. for
Arbitas
[Laughter]
[Music]
The systematic radicalization of youth
and children is evident in the
increasing number of mudras and mosques
that have emerged.
We found a madrasa nearby where a mole
was imparting theological lessons to
young children.
Come. Come.
How many
time.
According
[Music]
to late IPS officer RK Ori,
an anti-terror expert and the former
head of the internal security academy at
Mount Dabu.
There exist nearly 40 to 50 lakh mosques
in India.
each typically hosting an attached
madrasa or maktab for religious
education. The annual cost of
maintaining these institutions is a
staggering 1,400
cr rupees.
According to professor Mushiul Hak from
a mere 88 madras in 1947
the number skyrocketed to approximately
5 lakh by 2006.
In a compelling article titled Islamic
Madras Servicing and Challenges, Molana
Muhammad Khalim Siddaki revealed that by
2003 the number of madras had reached 1
lakh 25,000 with nearly 30 lakh students
enrolled.
A madrasa is an exclusivist theological
Islamic seminary where the curriculum
known as darasay nami is deeply rooted
in Islamic theology and history
[Music]
in Islam.
refers to the six fundamental principles
of faith starting withhed
the one Allah affirming him as the sole
creator and sustainer risalah highlights
belief in Allah's messengers with
prophet Muhammad as the final prophet
Malika is the belief in angels divine
beings who execute Allah's commands
refers to to the revealed books
including the Quran the final and
unaltered scripture
or the day of judgment signifies
accountability for one's deeds.
Lastly, kadra or predestination teaches
that all events occur within Allah's
divine knowledge and plan.
[Music]
And when a young mind is indoctrinated
in a madrsa, what is done is his free
flowing thought process is confined to a
very limited and narrow-minded
definition of the divinity. As a result,
it inculcates into that young mind a
very false sense of self-righteousness
which leads to the slippery path of
radicalization. Madras mushroomed in
Tamad in the late 80s. It is because of
the Saudi Arabia funding after a series
of conversions in Ramadarum and the
infamous Vinaki in Tamil district. So
what before the those madrasa era you
can see many Tamar scholars among us
Muslims. This Madrasa has taken the
Muslims away from the Tamar identity and
that is the beginning point of violent
terror activities in Tamnad.
Over
three lakh 60,000 students are stuck in
the 18th century being educated in
around 3,000 madrasas located in the
capital of India, New Delhi.
A deep dive into the madrasa syllabus as
meticulously documented by Dendra Mittal
in his book Hindustan Madrasi unveils a
troubling reality. According to Mika,
students are indoctrinated to worship
only Allah.
>> Often taught in Arabic, Udu or Persian,
emphasis is placed on the Quran, Sharia,
Hadith, and the historical conquests of
Islamic warriors.
The core ideological teachings in Madras
center around fundamental concepts such
as the m or believer, Im meaning faith,
kafir referring to a non-believer,
dhava which is invitation to Islam,
and jihad often interpreted as a war
against kafirs.
or unbelievers.
>> Uh I've seen hearts being carved out of
bodies. I have seen um duct tape being
placed on pe men's eyes and then they
stand them on the mass graves and shoot
them and and they don't die and then
they beat them after they have shot
them. The humanization that is happening
on the ground. They make them bark like
dogs. They make them walk on four on on
legs and their uh hands on on their
knees and hands. It is absolutely an
atrocity.
>> When a radical Muslim is pushing the
button of his suicide vest and exploding
or when he is flying a plane into a
building, he is visualizing himself as a
shahid in the way of Allah. The the
technical term isal
and he is visualizing that this god
called Allah on the day of judgment is
going to award him a door to jennut
because of his act against the
non-Muslims.
January 10, 2018. An India Today
investigation reveals that several
Madras in Kerala teach vahabism, an
extremist ideology linked to ISIS, which
is supported by Havala funding from Gulf
countries.
Whether this is where ISIS ideology is
being taught, what we found will shock
you.
Allah all
100%.
>> These seminaries are indoctrinating
young minds with the goal of
establishing a global caliphate. Key
figures admitted to subtly instilling
radical ideas in children and showing
Zakir Nayak videos to promote extremist
views.
>> Each and every people know who is Zaknik
and something like that.
>> The investigation highlights the covert
spread of this ideology in Kerala.
officials who run these madrasas talking
about how bit by bit they teach Wahhabi
extremist ideology and they're saying so
in their own words I always went for the
Friday prayers in a salafi masjid and
there we will be given the sermons in
the local language and in that what you
are listening you are listening about
not to take part in the onam celebration
that's the state celebration here in
Kerala you are not supposed to take part
in onam You are not supposed to cut a
cake on Christmas. And if you do that,
even if in the name of coexistence, in
the name of religious harmony, you are
against Islam and you are doing
something that is shik. The curriculum
advises against forming friendships with
idol worshippers known as kafirs whose
fate they are taught is eternal
damnation.
Among the core teachings are the
concepts of waging jihad and
establishing Islamic rule across India.
If this is not radicalization,
what is
[Music]
Islam.
coexistence with kafir is not allowed.
You even talk about going to Syria or
even to Afghanistan for jihad because
that's your ultimate duty.
for
bakra.
Bakra number
for
Saudi Arabia
translation
fight.
meaning
jihad means that it's a war against
infidels which will continue till the
day of judgment.
The question is whether the children
are taught
that
the punishment for blasphemy
is beheading
and they are being taught in our own
institutions in India. The term used in
verse 33 of surah Maida is fitna
which is generally translated as causing
corruption in the land or waging war
against Allah or its prophet. So these
all things come under the ambit of what
is loosely termed as blasphemy and it
definitely is a part of Islam. It is not
some interpretation which has been done
by some radical Muslim. It is Islam. You
remember the beheadings and the videos
of the beheadings that the Islamic State
put out and it was repulsive. Why are
they doing it? The Quran says chapter
47:4 when you meet the unbelievers
strike the necks. The only solution that
Islam reforms itself that Islam starts
looking you know at
you know and deleting this part of the
encourage you know violence that
encourage you know force conversion that
encourage suicide bombers that encourage
you know uh uh growing up and taking
over countries you know Islam has to
reform itself you know
>> till the day of the judgment the war
against infidels will be continued And
that war will be waged with ferocity
which will ensure that either the entire
world converts to Islam or they are they
are anhilated they are destroyed.
>> In these madrasas students are being
instructed by molanas on the concept of
dhawa an invitation for non-believers to
embrace Islam as the sole truth.
The moment you find a kafir, the first
thing that will come to your mind is to
identify a chance to do dawa.
They are also warned that refusal to
accept this call could lead to the
declaration of jihad against them.
Let me tell you that the attack on
Israeli civilians and the holiday goers
on the 7th October 2023 was an act
against humanity. The manner in which
the brutality was unleashed on the
civilians and the militia of Israel is
beyond compare. And indeed, I would say
you really have to try very hard to
restrain your tears. The manner in which
the young babies were thrown into
burning patrol, the women were
brutalized, their dead bodies were
desecrated. Well, what can I say that
the brutality seems to be a part of the
Hamas DNA? We find that in Kashmir a
very similar thing happened.
>> Not similar. In fact, a photocopy, an
exact replica of what happened there.
You would realize that the jihadi
genocide sees no national boundaries.
What happened to Israel happened to us
in Pelgam on 22nd of April. Nathanu said
that every member of the Hamas is a dead
man and he'll be hunted down wherever he
is in the world. Prime Minister Modi
said that he will hunt down the
terrorist wherever they are.
[Music]
Dawa, the Islamic practice of inviting
non-Muslims to convert was weaponized in
a terror plot exposed by the National
Investigation Agency, NIA. On June 2,
2023, the NIA dismantled an ISIS linked
module in Jabalpur, Madhya Pradesh,
revealing a plan to convert India into
an Islamic nation by 2050.
At the core was the Dawa to Hindus
document.
A 20chapter manifesto filled with
venomous lies and distortions slandering
Hindu gods like Lord Ram and Lord Shiv
and perverting scriptures to push an
extremist agenda.
Ayan Hi Ali, author of the challenge of
dawa and a vocal critic of radical Islam
highlights the fundamental role of da'wa
the Islamic practice of procelitizing.
>> And you've written this book about it.
The challenge of dawa.
>> Yeah.
>> Which I'm sure I'm mispronouncing. Would
you just first of all pronounce it
correctly and then tell us what it
means?
>> Dawa is the way it's pronounced. And
what it means uh is to plead or to call
non-Muslims to Islam. And then in the 10
years in Medina that followed the call,
the invitation, the persuasion, the use
of language slowly transformed, maybe
not so slowly, transformed into the use
of force. So da
are all the steps that precede jihad.
[Music]
She explains that Dhava manuals act as
blueprints for cultural dominance,
subtly guiding followers to impose
Islamic norms on societies.
This gradual shift, she warns, can pave
the way for jihad and the enforcement of
Sharia law.
Ayan Hi Ali speaking at the Hoover
Institution draws on the philosophy of
KL PA who famously argued against
tolerating intolerance. Ali warns that
modern societies in the name of
tolerance often allow the spread of
extremist ideologies like communism and
radical Islamism.
She emphasizes that these ideologies
including the practice of dhava pose
significant threats to global peace and
stability. By tolerating such intolerant
beliefs, societies risk undermining
their own values and freedoms.
Ali's message is clear. To protect our
world, we must not tolerate the spread
of ideologies that seek to destroy it.
>> If we go back to the papa principle
where our society then says enough is
enough, the constitution is not suicide
pact, we can agree on trying to fight
this particular ideology the way we
fought previous ideologies with the same
outcomes.
[Applause]
As the president of the US in his first
term, Donald Trump made a bold and rare
move in modern history by taking a
strong ideological stance against
radical Islam.
Nor can we let the hateful ideology of
radical Islam, its oppression of women,
gays, children, and non-believers be
allowed to reside or spread within our
own countries.
[Applause]
We must have to defeat radical Islamic
terrorism.
[Applause]
But just like we couldn't defeat
communism without acknowledging that
communism exists,
we're explaining its horrible evils. We
can't defeat radical Islamic terrorism
unless we do the exact same thing. We
have to explain that it exists.
[Applause]
That is why one of my first acts as
president will be to establish a
commission on radical Islam.
>> President Donald Trump calling on Arab
leaders to do their share to fight
Islamic extremism Sunday during his
speech in Riyad, Saudi Arabia.
>> Drive them out. Drive them out of your
places of worship. Drive them out of
your communities. Drive them out of your
holy land and drive them out of this
earth.
>> Is there a new moment here or was he
just being a chump like other American
presidents? But if he stood there
talking to the king of Saudi Arabia,
then then this is the crucible of Da um
that would be a completely different
conversation. And I don't think from a
diplomatic perspective that that's the
kind of conversation you want to have in
public.
>> Mhm. I think behind closed doors it
would make a great deal of sense to use
you know the Trumpian language of
explicitness and say this is what we we
it's the da it's the ideas and the
ideology and the principles of Sharia of
jihad of commanding rights and
forbidding wrong he'll have to get
fluent in that himself first.
On March 12, 2001, the world watched in
horror as the Taliban reduced the
Bameyan Buddhas to rubble.
For 1,500
years, the majestic Bameyian Buddha
statues, the towering monolithic giants,
stood as a symbol of universalism
and peace.
[Music]
Dr. Britkar reveals a significant fact.
The Persian word b meaning idol
originates from Buddha highlighting the
prevalence of Buddha idols in ancient
Buddhism. Islamic invaders who rejected
idol worship targeted these Buddha idols
leading to a destructive campaign
against Buddhism. Ancient universities
like Nalanda were sacked and monasteries
raised. Thousands of monks fled or were
killed erasing a rich cultural heritage.
[Applause]
Allah
[Music]
ISIS driven by a radical ideology has
waged a devastating campaign against
Christianity in Iraq, Syria, and beyond.
Their propaganda films glorify the
bombing of churches and the destruction
of crosses.
[Applause]
This violent iconoclasm underscores
their mission to erase religious
diversity and impose their extremist
vision, causing widespread devastation
to Christian heritage and communities
across the region.
[Music]
Historian Di Kosambi confirms that in
about 1,200 AD,
raiders under Muhammad bin Baktiar
Khalji
destroyed the tremendous complex at
Sarnath.
This doctrine of iconoclasm branding the
mere existence of images and idols as
heretical continues to echo through the
acts of the believers fostering a cycle
of intolerance and violence.
During Ganesh Jhaterti in September
1983, Hyderabad witnessed one of its
worst communal riots, leaving 43 people
dead. Knife wielding gangs roamed the
streets, escalating violence that was
fueled by deep-seated religious and
political tensions. Central doctrine of
Islam as any Muslim will tell you ished
which means to declare as one to make
into one that is to say monotheism to
say that God is one. So what follows
from this is that everything else except
God should not be woripped. That is why
if Hindus carry around the the idol the
Morty of let's say Ganesa then that's a
valid target for attack.
>> In the year 2024 Ganesh Jhaterti
witnessed a shocking wave of violence
erupt across India.
These brutal attacks trace back to the
self-righteous ideology of iconoclasm.
They hate idol worship while portraying
Hindu deities as demonic entities.
With 17 reported serious incidents, this
orchestrated violence appears to be a
calculated and wellplanned effort to
strike fear and disruption during a
cherished Hindu festival.
Stone pelting, arson, and chaos erupted,
marking a disturbing escalation in
radical attempts to intimidate dharmic
communities.
It was as if the theocratic oppression
faced by Hindus in neighboring Pakistan
and Bangladesh was being imposed within
India itself.
According
to the late IPS officer RK Ori, after
the year 2000, Saudi Arabia alone has
rolled out nearly 90 billion US for
propagation of Wahhabi Islam through
establishment of thousands of mosques
and madrasas. More than 25% of the 90
billion in petro dollars have been
funneled into India, Nepal and
Bangladesh to establish additional
madrasas.
Significant funds have also been
transferred from other Muslim nations
including Pakistan to support the
proliferation of mudras across South
Asia, intensifying the global jihad
campaign. According
to security experts, the increasing
number of Madras globally has
significantly contributed to the rise of
terrorism over the past several decades.
This trend is evident in various regions
including Kashmir where a surge in
Madras funded by Pakistan's ISI and Gulf
charities preceded the secessionist
movement.
[Music]
An intelligence bureau report stated
that between 2011 and 2013 25,000
Wahhabi preachers visited India holding
seminars across several states.
These activities signaled a covert
effort to reshape the country's
religious landscape and advance Saudi
geopolitical interests.
In June 2015, Wikileaks revealed a major
transfer from Saudi Arabia to India
amounting to rupees 1,700
cr. This money was used to promote the
Wahhabi belief system.
The goal was to counter Iran's growing
influence among India's Shia community.
It was part of a broader strategy to
limit Iran's impact in the region.
>> Each time a Saudi sponsored Wahhabi
preacher arrives in India, he brings a
rule book dictating strict guidelines.
Shrines shall be forbidden. Muslim women
must wear pararda or face severe
punishment. Men must grow beards and
wear trousers above their ankles. Women
should not work unless absolutely
necessary. Public mingling of men and
women is prohibited. Loud weeping at
funerals, listening to music, dancing,
and watching television are banned.
Several prestigious academic studies
highlight the alarming connection
between Madras and terrorism.
The Rand Corporation and a World Bank
study emphasize how Madras in South Asia
can foster militancy.
The international crisis group ICG found
that Pakistani Madras affiliated with
the Bandhi and Eile hadith sects were
more likely to be involved in militant
activities.
These religious schools which provide
free education and lodging have received
external funding especially from Gulf
countries. The report highlights the
need for reform and regulation to
address extremism within the Madrasa
system. In 2004,
Perves Hudboy a professor at Islamabad's
K Aam University wrote in foreign
affairs that Pakistani schools including
Madras produce zealots driven by jihad
and martyrdom. library period
computer science
school or mother
[Music]
according to the New York-based
combating terrorism center West point.
Structured interviews with over 100
students from four Indonesian Madras
revealed striking correlation between
unusual belief systems and
radicalization.
While schools like Darus Salam and Al
Husseini promote a more moderate form of
Islam, others such as Al-Islam Madrasa,
Tangolu, East Java stand out for their
extreme teachings. At Al-Islam Madrasa,
91% of students believe that it is their
duty to fight and kill non-Muslims. a
stark contrast to the 35% at other
institutions.
Additionally, students who think people
are inherently evil are 11 times more
likely to support violence against
non-Muslims.
These findings underscore the dangerous
influence of radical madras in shaping
extreme ideologies and actions.
According to a paper published by
Mindanao State University in Moravi
City, Philippines, a significantly
higher number of girls attending Madras
have undergone female circumcision
compared to those receiving western
education.
The study highlights religious
justifications as the primary driving
force behind the continued prevalence of
the practice.
Researchers found that in rural areas
across Lana delsur, female circumcision
remains widespread with cultural and
religious beliefs deeply influencing
local communities.
[Music]
Despite efforts to modernize education
and healthcare, the study underscores
the persistence of this tradition,
particularly in more isolated regions.
Female genital mutilation,
FGM, is tied to the same extremist
ideologies that fuel terrorism, as noted
by Ayan Hiy Ali. At the age of five, my
genitals were cut. And when I was old
enough to ask why did that happen, my
grandmother was very, you know, she
readily explained it as, well, we
purified you and if you are not
purified, you'll never find a husband.
So that kind of practice is and it isn't
something that happened only to me. It
happened to and it happens according to
United Nations numbers to 98% of Somali.
>> She emphasizes how certain mudras
perpetuate both violence and FGM a
practice causing severe pain infections
and lasting trauma.
UNICEF reports that over 20 cr girls and
women across 30 countries have endured
FGM with over five lakh affected in
Europe alone.
>> There's over 135,000 women and girls in
the UK who have been directly affected
by FGM. 43% of those are aged between 5
and 9. FGM has been illegal in the UK
since 1985.
Since 2003, anyone convicted faces 14
years in prison. This is totally
irrelevant though as there's yet to be a
single conviction or prosecution in over
30 years.
>> Supreme Court has questioned the
practice of genital mutilation among
minor girls
Bora Muslim community. The Supreme Court
has questioned the practice of genital
mutilation among minor girls of Dawudi
Bora Muslim community. Court also said
that genital mutilation was an attack on
the right to privacy.
[Music]
In the year 2002 in India, former West
Bengal Chief Minister Buddhave Bhachara
of the Communist Party of India Marxist
took a decisive stance against the
unchecked proliferation of Madras
advocating a shift towards modern
secular education.
The problem is that some madrasas
they are not joining the mainstream.
They're not getting affiliated to
madrasa board and they are teaching only
Arabic language and theology. I feel
that Muslim community should understand
this problem and they should change this
policy and they should come to the
mainstream.
His bold move sparked fierce backlash
from both the so-called secular and
Islamist establishments.
[Applause]
Assam's chief minister Himanta
Biswasarma has also been a vocal
proponent of regulating mudras to curb
radicalization
implementing policies to transform some
of these institutions into mainstream
schools.
We are demonstrating madras run by
jihadi. We have sufficient troop against
them.
>> Lot of troops. They have a lot of proof
against them. Then only we do such kind
of demolish activities.
>> August 3, 2022.
India's security agencies are on high
alert due to unexpected demographic
shifts along the India Nepal border. In
Uttar Pradesh, 116 border villages have
become Muslim majority with the Muslim
population increasing by 32% since 2011.
October 3, 2023,
Nepal faced a disturbing incident in the
Bet district of Nepal Gange as communal
clashes erupted between Hindu and
Islamist groups. The tension began on
October 1 during an e milad procession
where Islamist groups raised provocative
slogans like sansi juda inciting
violence. This led to stone pelting and
arson against Hindus. In response a
Hindu group organized a peaceful protest
which was met with hostility and attacks
escalating the conflict.
Meanwhile, the chief minister of Uttar
Pradesh, Yogi Adityanad, a shining star
of the BJP and a Hindutwa icon has
undertaken firm measures to dradicalize
Madras and bring them under government
oversight.
October 23, 2023.
The Uttar Pradesh government has
launched a special investigation team
SIT to probe 4,000 Madras along the
Indonespal border
suspected of receiving foreign funds.
According to the SIT, such funds help
promote terror related activities or
forced religious conversions.
As we approach the Darul Ulum Dioand
Madrasa of 1866 in western Uttar
Pradesh, there's an unmistakable sense
of apprehension. This institution, an
international center for Islamic
learning, has often been flagged by
global security experts as a breeding
ground for jihadis.
MJ Abbar aptly noted, "Jihad is the
signature tune of Islamic history."
And perhaps this is where the first
chords were struck.
Moolah Muhammad Omar born in 1960 in
Kandahar founded the Taliban in 1994.
He was educated at Pakistan's Dubandi
Seminary called the Darul Ulum Hakania.
[Music]
His rise and the Taliban's eventual
strangle hold over Afghanistan was
deeply rooted in the Deoandhi teachings
he absorbed.
The ideological ties between the Taliban
and Pakistan's Madras are undeniable.
B. Raman, former head of
counterterrorism at India's research and
analysis wing, exposed the direct
connections between Pakistan's doandhi
seminaries and jihadi networks.
He warned that these institutions rather
than being passive religious schools
serve as militant factories.
Pakistan is not just negligent, it is
complicit.
Rammon emphasized that Pakistan's
intelligence agencies see these
militants as strategic assets in their
geopolitical games, particularly in
India and Afghanistan.
The Hakani network responsible for
countless atrocities in Afghanistan
draws its roots from these very
seminaries.
The same goes for Jes Muhammad which is
behind major terror strikes in India.
[Applause]
The 2014 Peshawar school massacre by the
TTP highlighted the group's deep roots
in the Dioandhi movement.
The Dioandhi school of thought is known
for its strict and puritanical beliefs.
They have been fostering intolerance
towards Shia and others labeled as kafir
or infidols.
This ideology is mainly propagated
through the Tabligi Jamaat missionary
group.
This process has tragically contributed
to the targeting and radicalization of
young people.
It is imperative that international
human rights organizations
raise awareness and protect the
vulnerable Shia minorities in Pakistan
from such hatred and violence.
Lashkar Jangvi notorious for its
sectarian violence has unleashed horrors
on Pakistan's Shia population all in the
name of Dandhi extremism
[Applause]
the Rahul Pindi Ashuram A massacre of
2012 and the Queta bombings of 2013 are
grim reminders of Pakistan's deep-seated
sectarian violence against the Shia
community.
The Shia community in Pakistan has
endured a relentless wave of violence.
From 2001 to 2018, a staggering 4,847
Shia lost their lives to sectarian
attacks.
[Applause]
The terror escalated between 2012 and
2015 with over 1,900
Shia killed in bombings and targeted gun
attacks.
The nightmare persisted from 2021 to
2023,
claiming more than 1,900 lives and
leaving over 1,100
injured.
[Music]
Each number represents a precious life
extinguished, a family shattered, and a
community living in fear.
These acts of terror along with the
countless attacks on Shia mosques reveal
Pakistan's hand in fueling both
sectarian and global jihadi movements.
The huge attacks which have happened in
Pakistan against Shia where thousands of
Shia have been killed. It emanates from
the attacks by the Dubandis. What is the
reason? Well, the attacks on the Shia
are ultimately the same phenomenon as
attacks on Hindus or other unbelievers.
Namely,
they are some sort of apostates. They
are some sort of non-Muslims
in a sense that they have a different
view of the basic teachings of Islam.
Pakistan's complicity is unmistakable.
As long as these seminaries are allowed
to function without consequences, they
will continue to produce extremists who
threaten regional and global security.
The world must not only recognize
Pakistan's role but hold it accountable.
January 5, 2022, Chief Minister Yogi
Adityanath took a bold step by laying
the foundation stone for an
anti-terrorism squad ATS commando
training center in Duband, Saharanpur.
This location will now host 56 elite
commandos. Aditin delivered a clear
message to terrorists.
[Applause]
[Music]
spanning over 2,000 square m. The center
will monitor communally sensitive areas
of western Uttar Pradesh. This move is
part of a larger plan with similar
centers being built across the state in
sensitive places like Mirat, Baharaj,
Shravasti and Gotham Bud Naga to fortify
national security.
[Music]
February 22, 2024,
it was reported by the press and various
TV channels all over the world. A query
was put before the Dharul Ulum Dubai.
Does the hadith mention the invasion of
India known as the Gazw which will take
place in the subcontinent and whoever
will be martyed in it would be
proclaimed as a great martyr and the one
who will be Razi will go to heaven.
Janmad please reply
the prestigious seat of Islam the
Darulum Duband Madrasa replied in
affirmative. It was shocking indeed that
the Duban Madrasa itself welcomed an
attack on India called Gazwin.
The Madrasa claims that those who died
during the invasion of India will be
called great martyrs and will go to
heaven.
Jenna's demand for a corridor linking
west and east Pakistan was driven by his
ambition to unify Muslim majority
regions. A vision that aligns with the
Dand Fatwa for Gazwin, the conquest of
India. As documented in VP Menon's the
transfer of power, Jimna's proposal
raised suspicions with Congress leaders
strongly opposing it. Although the
viceroyy's intervention halted the plan,
its echoes have persisted.
Rahmed Ali who coined the name Pakistan
in his 1933 pamphlet now or never laid
the ideological foundation with a map
advocating for an expansive Muslim state
which shaped Jina's corridor vision.
Decades later in 2003, physicist Dr. JK
Bajage identified a demographic corridor
forming between Pakistan and Bangladesh
eerily resembling Jina's original plan.
This was later corroborated by the ISI
backed Muralistan Research Institute's
map emphasizing the ongoing demographic
and strategic aggression. The alignment
of Jinda's corridor with Gazbai Him
reflects a deeper long-term plan for
geopolitical dominance in the region.
As far as I can see, there is a global
design to to create a South Asian
caliphate.
[Music]
On July 25, 2024, the UPATS exposed a
terrorist network linked to Darul Ulum
Duban involving foreign funding for
mosques and settling Rohingya Muslims in
Indian cities.
The plot included plans to build mosques
near the Pakistan and Bangladesh
borders. The ATS continues to
investigate the network's roots and
funding sources. The coldblooded
behavior pattern of Rohingya terrorists
can be determined from Amnesty
International's report of August 2017.
The report showed that they were
responsible for the brutal massacre of
99 Hindus in Myanmar's Rakin state. By
September 2017, a government of India
affidavit confirmed that 40,000 Rohhinga
Muslims had entered India. However,
unofficial estimates suggest the number
could be 10 times higher.
>> Tamunad is an obvious destination for
Rohingya. Some Muslim organizations they
go and hand over children from Rohingya
camps to people belonging to the Muslim
communities from Indian origin and
likewise
it is not only Rohhinga settlement which
is happening it is Rohhinga procreation
is also happening in Tamag
>> with ties to ISIS and Pakistan-based
terror groups. Rohhinga are involved in
human trafficking, drug smuggling and
circulating fake currency. Rohhinga
settlements near critical military
installations like Sanjuan and Nagroa
army camps along with vital
infrastructure like Indian oil depots
and railway tracks pose a direct
national security threat. UPCM Yogi
Adityanat now faces a critical moment to
stop this growing threat before it
spirals further.
According to PEW research, the Muslim
population in Europe has experienced
significant growth. In 1990, Europe was
home to around 2 cr 96 lakh Muslims. By
2010, that number increased to 4 cr 41
lakhs and projections now suggest that
it will surpass 5 cr 80 lakhs by 2030.
Currently, Muslims make up about 6% of
Europe's total population, up from 4.1%
in 1990. By 2030, they're expected to
account for roughly 8%.
This growth is particularly evident in
countries like France, Germany, and the
UK, driven by migration and higher birth
rates.
Author Ed Hussein's Among the Mosques
reveals how changing demographics are
driving segregation and fear in parts of
the UK. In Blackburn, where nearly 30%
of the population is Muslim, white
residents report no go areas like Valley
Range, where one father says his
12-year-old son was attacked five times
just for being white.
We're seeing an organized minority
who've produced almost kind of 42,000
terror suspects which are under MI5's
watch. That's serious. And if Muslims
and more mosques emerge without that
cancer uprooted, then what we're looking
at is something much more serious.
Hussein observes that in towns like
Bradford and Dubsbury with Muslim
populations exceeding 25%
communities are physically in Britain
but mentally living elsewhere with
Talibanike restrictions on women and
children.
>> I'm Raheem Kasam, editor. Raheem Kasam,
author of Nogo Zones, similarly warns
that unchecked migration and parallel
communities are fracturing social
cohesion in cities like Birmingham and
Luton.
These findings suggest a growing divide
tied directly to demographic shifts,
raising urgent questions about
integration and national unity. And this
channel was roundly attacked for
asserting that there were parts of Paris
where non-Muslims couldn't go, a no-go
zone. And the left in the US said that's
outrageous. It's bigoted even to suggest
something like that. You just wrote a
book on it. I traveled across Europe and
even to places in the United States uh
where I see Sharia law emanating, where
I see uh dominant Muslim populations
dictating what can and does happen in
their neighborhoods. I've seen areas in
which terrorists find enclaves and find
shelter. I found places that actually uh
young white girls just can't go
otherwise they're harassed and set upon.
Elon Musk's tweet on grooming gangs
exposed a harrowing truth. The
systematic sexual exploitation of
children in the UK predominantly by men
of Pakistani origin.
There were um migrant rape gangs in in
England that would gangs that would run
around and prey on young girls, gang
rape them.
>> And some people found that
objectionable, which obviously it should
be objectionable. Um and uh they were
upset about that and so they complained
about it online
and were sent to prison.
[Music]
Musk criticized politicians for staying
silent, accusing them of complicity in
failing to protect victims out of fear
of being labeled racist. This silence
has allowed decades of abuse to go
unchecked.
In England alone, almost 19,000 children
were sexually groomed in just one year,
according to the Independent. Home
Secretary Sarjett Javeed ordered an
investigation into why members of sexual
grooming gangs were disproportionately
from a Pakistani background.
>> 20% of the Muslim men in Telford were
involved in prostituting and raping
children. Five women are dead including
children in that town. This is just one
small town called Telford with 3 and a
half thousand Muslims in it. In India,
child grooming, also known as love
jihad, is a growing concern with reports
of online and offline exploitation on
the rise.
Child grooming is a sinister process
where adults build trust with children
online or in person to manipulate and
exploit them for sexual purposes.
[Applause]
This heinous crime has reached epidemic
proportions globally. Rotherham is a
charming town nestled in South
Yorkshire, England.
Here the rolling hills of the Penines
meet the industrial heritage of the
north. This is home to warmhearted
gentlemen and ladies who are law-abiding
citizens who embody the values of
community and resilience.
But beneath its adilic facade, a dark
secret lurked. Between 2003 and 2008,
seven individuals committed unimaginable
crimes, grooming, drugging, raping, and
assaulting vulnerable girls, some as
young as 11 and 15.
These heinous acts, part of a systemic
child abuse scandal, shattered 1,400
innocent lives and left lifelong scars.
In September of 2024,
justice was served.
The seven perpetrators were collectively
jailed for 106 years with sentences
ranging from 10 to 19 years.
[Music]
Sweden, a nation renowned for its
kindness, leads the world in compassion.
From protecting animals to embracing
vegetarianism and veganism, its society
is built on care and inclusivity.
In 2015, Sweden extended this compassion
to over 1 lakh 63,000 Muslim refugees,
offering them sanctuary during Europe's
largest migration wave. With a
population of just 1 cr, Sweden welcomed
more migrants per capita than any other
European country, driven by a desire to
provide safety to those fleeing war and
hardship. But this generosity faced a
bitter betrayal.
>> In the small town of Ostroen, once known
for its peaceful streets, women became
targets of brutal assaults. Police for
the first time warned women not to walk
alone at night after multiple attacks by
foreign men. The violence shocked the
nation known for its commitment to
gender equality.
>> The sexual violence is increasing
because of the number of immigrant men
from Muslim majority countries
um who are responsible for most of these
not all of them but for most of these.
The heartbreak continued in Malmo where
a group of Arab migrants filmed
themselves pushing a Ukrainian refugee
into a freezing river, laughing as he
struggled to survive.
In 2020, Sweden implemented stringent
measures to curb foreign influence on
religious schools amid rising concerns
over extremism in immigrant communities.
The government tightened regulations
ensuring schools adhered to secular and
democratic values.
Teachers now face an unimaginable
struggle in Muslim migrant nogo zones
like Yva Stockholm.
A 60-year-old teacher is called dirty by
students simply for being white and
Christian. These students, many from
immigrant backgrounds, lash out at those
who defer from them. Parents attend
school meetings in bulletproof vests due
to rampant gun violence.
>> Even the parents who visit their school
children.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh they have to go in bulletproof vests
because of the firing which happens in
those schools in nobo areas. and they
wanted to make native Swedes the
minority and bring in everyone and so
they have realized that this experiment
hasn't really succeeded that this has
gone too far but now they are doing what
is necessary so I mean on this we have
to complement it they are realistic they
are doing what is you know called for
you know unlike some other countries
where this is not possible in Holland
also So similarly you see a number of
right-wing or you know middle centrist
parties getting together and pursuing
this agenda.
>> Despite the constant threats many
teachers remain believing in the power
of education.
The Swedish government desperate to keep
educators in these dangerous zones
offers bonus pay.
But is money enough? Will we allow those
who dedicate their lives to educating
our children to be terrorized?
According
to the prestigious international think
tank Thunder,
France has been the most affected
country by Islamist violence in the
European Union
with 85 terror attacks leading to 334
deaths between 1979
and 2024.
[Music]
Globally, leaders like French President
Emmanuel Macaron have implemented
policies to regulate Islamic educational
institutions, including Madras, as part
of a broader strategy to combat radical
Islamism.
Even the madrasas imparting Islamic
education regulations are coming in
France by a progressive leftist almost
leftist macro.
>> Unlike in many other countries in France
a critical mass of secularists still has
that reflex. We don't want religious
encroachment on the public space.
Macaron's government introduced the
anti-seeparatism bill which allows for
increased scrutiny of religious
institutions, mandates transparency in
funding and provides the state with the
power to shut down madras that promote
extremist ideologies.
Under the legislation, women refusing to
take the nikab off will be fined nearly
$200.
Additionally, the law emphasizes the
need for a secular curriculum and
requires children to attend public
schools to prevent radicalization from
an early age. These actions reflect a
growing recognition worldwide of the
need to balance religious education with
national security and social cohesion.
What would you say about the
anti-Islamic or the right-wing movement
which is gaining ground in many
countries of Europe? Ask your star dare
to put it, you know, it's it's a
right-wing conspiracy and so on. Not at
all. This is very mainstream. This is
just back to normal.
In June 2023, France witnessed
widespread riots following the police
shooting of 17-year-old
Nahil Marzuk, igniting chaos led by
Algerian immigrants and their
supporters.
Public buildings, cars, and shops were
torched, and the Jewish community faced
targeted anti-semitic attacks.
Islamist
figures like Ayat Urai gloated, framing
the mayhem as justified revenge against
France for its perceived crimes against
Muslims. Despite President Maro
condemning the incident,
regimes like Iran with their own
atrocious human rights records seized
the opportunity to criticize France.
Macar's 2020 reforms aimed at
integrating Muslim immigrants and
countering Islamist extremism have only
intensified backlash from Islamist
groups who accuse him of leading a
campaign against Islam.
In 2022, Italy under Prime Minister
George Miloney took decisive action by
introducing laws to curb foreign funding
of Islamic schools, signaling a
commitment to protecting Italy's secular
values.
Melon's policies placed Italy alongside
other European nations, fighting
radicalization through education
reforms.
In response to the 2017 Vienna attack,
Austria passed a series of reforms under
Chancellor Sebastian Kurs. Austrian
authorities shut down Madras linked to
extremism, banned foreign funding for
Islamic institutions, and cracked down
on religious schools promoting radical
ideologies.
[Music]
The United European Front, from Milan's
reforms in Italy to Macaron's leadership
in France and Wilder's longstanding
advocacy in the Netherlands highlights a
continentwide commitment to defending
secular and democratic values. Europe's
fight to curb extremism in religious
education continues to play a critical
role in securing the future of the
continent against radical Islamic
ideologies.
[Music]
Outrage erupted in Turkey after a
concert in Riyad featured the KBA's
silhouette as stage decor, sparking
accusations of disrespect towards Islam.
[Music]
On November 14, 2024,
Riad hosted the once unthinkable, a
glittering celebration for Ellie Saab's
45th anniversary,
[Music]
featuring stars like Jennifer Lopez,
Selene Dion and Camila Cabello.
Over 1,000 guests grooved on music,
costumes, and glamour.
A stark break from Saudi Arabia's
illiberal past.
It was a cultural shock,
a display of western opulence and bold
self-exression.
While not true female empowerment, it
marked a radical shift under Muhammad
bin Salman, a nation boldly departing
from its frosty medieval, closed, and
conservative past to embrace a new era
of openness.
[Music]
In September 2017, MBS announced that
women would be allowed to drive, ending
a decadesl long prohibition.
This landmark decision effective June
24, 2018 enhanced women's independence
and mobility, marking a major milestone
in their empowerment.
By June 2018, women were allowed to
attend sports events in stadiums for the
first time. This move signaled the
beginning of greater inclusion in public
entertainment and sports sectors,
breaking longstanding social barriers.
[Music]
In the vast expanse of the Arabian
desert, a revolution is quietly taking
shape.
Crown Prince Muhammad bin Salman, MBS,
is orchestrating a remarkable
transformation of Saudi Arabia.
This is not merely an economic overhaul.
It's a profound shift in ideology,
lifestyle, and global influence.
For decades, Saudi Arabia's oil wealth
has been the lifeblood of its economy
and a major source of its influence.
This wealth funded the spread of
Wahhabism. A strict interpretation of
Islam. With every rise in oil prices,
the kingdom's ability to promote this
ideology grew.
But now MBS is forging a new path. His
reforms are extensive and
groundbreaking.
According to reports, Saudi Arabia's
transformation includes a selective
interpretation of hadith by setting
aside those texts that have justified
extreme practices. For example,
restrictions on women's movement and
dress are being re-examined, aligning
religious teachings with modern values
like gender equality.
You know what the the scholars are
saying? If you go up and see what all
the scholars are saying, they're saying
this would relegate only 10% of the
hadith therefore are authoritative.
>> Yeah.
>> 10%.
If you look at it in a historical
context of what societies had to go
through to neuter their conservative
right-wing religious class that usually
only happened with civil wars. This has
all happened without a single cleric
being, you know, killed or no violence
on the streets. And I think that is
virtually miraculous.
We are developing the first phase of our
cognitive city, the line, the
re-imagined industrial city.
>> At the heart of Saudi Arabia's vision
2030 lies the Neon project,
a groundbreaking development with an
estimated cost now exceeding $1.5
trillion as reported by the Wall Street
Journal.
[Music]
More than just a city, NEON is
envisioned as a transformative hub for
innovation, sustainability, and
cuttingedge technologies like AI.
Renewable energy and smart
infrastructure.
It represents a pivotal step in reducing
the kingdom's dependence on oil revenues
and reshaping its global image.
The massive funding demands of NEOM
leave little room for financing
initiatives linked to bahabism and
panislamic terrorism.
Instead, NEOME prioritizes global
competitiveness, transparency, and a
vision of progress,
inclusivity, and modern living.
70% of the Saudi people are less than 30
years old, and quite frankly, we will
not waste 30 years of our lives in
dealing with extremist ideas. We will
destroy them today.
If Muhammad bin Salman succeeds, his
legacy could mirror Gorbachov's glass
nost and peristrika
driving a much needed renaissance in the
Islamic world.
[Music]
Islam is reforming itself from within
like it has in Saudi Arabia like it has
in Abu Dhabi and in the emirates. I was
surprised and delighted to see a lovely
axar dham temple which has come up on
the soil of Abu Dhabi with the
permission and encouragement of the
shakes of Abu Dhabi.
This is CBN News Watch.
>> Iranians are growing tired of the
Ayatollas and a nation led by the empty
promises of their Islamic theocracy. An
anonymous internal poll found that 80%
now prefer a democratic government and
many are leaving Islam.
Iran too faces its own silent
revolution. Over 50,000 mosques have
reportedly closed, signaling a profound
societal shift.
[Music]
Women and youth spearhead resistance
through acts of defiance, removing
cleric turbles, challenging dress codes,
and reclaiming public spaces through
music and dance.
These actions reflect a growing demand
for freedom and modernization.
>> Paralleling Saudi Arabia's reforms but
arising from grassroots resistance
rather than topdown initiatives.
Mariam Namazi, she's an Iranian
ex-Muslim. She lives in UK. She had
already told internet is doing to Islam
what the printing press did to uh
Christianity.
>> In 2022, a young woman by the name of
Masa Amini was detained by Iran's
so-called morality police in Thran.
Amini was pulled into a police van. She
died in the hospital 3 days later.
In Iran, disillusioned citizens are
turning to Christianity, while ancient
faiths like Zoroastronism and Yazdanism
are witnessing a resurgence.
This movement reflects a yearning to
reconnect with pre-Islamic heritage,
sparking a cultural renaissance despite
government resistance.
Saudi Arabia's hundred billion dollar
investment in promoting Bahabism has
fueled radical ideologies destabilizing
nations such as Pakistan, Bangladesh and
India
and spreading extremism across Southeast
Asia and Africa.
While Crown Prince Muhammad bin Salman's
vision 2030 signifies a pivot towards
modernization,
the issue of reparations for past
damages remains unresolved.
Addressing this is crucial for genuine
reconciliation.
Though Saudi Arabia's transformation
brings benefits, it does not heal deeper
historical wounds.
Centuries of Mughal and Turic rule
inflicted lasting psychological scars on
Hindus through genocides and cultural
erasia factoring a once thriving
civilization.
The instances of iconoclasm all over the
country can be documented and have been
documented by scholars like Sitharam
Goyel.
These historical wounds resonate in
present-day challenges like land jihad,
no go zones and communal unrest fueled
by demographic aggression, terror rings
and foreign backed ideological warfare.
A chilling manifestation is unmitigated
love jihad.
Muslim men are accused of luring
non-Muslim women into Islam through
deception, coercion, and violence.
Reports trace this phenomenon to petro
dollar sponsored bahabism, radicalizing
groups like the popular front of India
and enabling lavish lifestyles that lure
victims into ideological traps.
Islam.
[Music]
Addressing these scars rooted in
systemic foreign sponsored extremism is
crucial for India to reclaim its
cultural identity and foster lasting
harmony.
[Music]
There's global condemnation for the
targeting of Hindus and other minorities
in Bangladesh.
[Applause]
The ousting of Shik Hassina has
triggered horrific violence against
minority Bangladeshi Hindus and
Buddhists.
Over 2,000 attacks have left dozens
dead, women raped,
>> and hundreds of temples destroyed,
including fatal attacks on Isk devotees.
Fueled by Madrasar radicalization often
funded under Saudi Bahabism, this
extremism continues to spread hatred and
instability.
[Applause]
Meanwhile, Pakistan's belligerance in
Kashmir and the western border
with ISI tentacles spread across the
country continues to destabilize the
region.
[Music]
India facing these dual threats from
Pakistan and Bangladesh
may be compelled to act decisively if
provocations persist.
The solution to your internalized
problems, you know, with jihadi, radical
Islam will come when the Indian armed
forces break up Pakistan into four or
five. Baluchistan, Pashon, Qua, right?
Uh, West Punjab, Sireia
and do you want to add Gilgate Pakistan?
You are welcome.
However, Saudi Arabia under Crown Prince
Muhammad bin Salman holds significant
influence over radical elements and can
play a crucial role in ensuring peace
and regional stability by curbing
extremist forces in both nations.
At this defining moment, MBS has a rare
opportunity to cement the sincerity of
his reforms.
reforms that echo the transformative
vision of Garbach's Glossnost and Parisa
as well as the bold modernization of
Mustafa Kamal Ataturk by championing
stability, inclusivity and progress. He
could not only reshape Saudi Arabia's
future, but also redefine its global
leadership, leaving a legacy that
resonates far beyond its borders.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Heat.
[Music]
Hey, Heat.